die skizzierung folgen ganz normaler
kassen vorgang ja richtig zum beispiel
wenn ihr haben wollt das volk gewandt
wir arbeiten sehr vielen mit diesem
scanner cutino hier siehst ganz klein
auf der seite ganz normal drüber ziehen
und dann erscheint der artikel von auf
dem bildschirm ok so tief vorne haben ja
diese liste der eu liste das bedeutet
bei swap ab da kannst du dann schauen
wenn der kunde zum beispiel eine banane
oder mehrere bananen darauf war dann
tipps die wir die nummer 1 macht das
kann mal die 4000 1
[Musik]
0761 mittel haben müssen bald unter
karte
fertige summe genau und dann drückst du
auf bezahlung
[Musik]
ja